brought to you by Final Fantasy 15
available on PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
November 29th back in 2006 not one not
two but three new Final Fantasy games
were announced Final Fantasy 13 Final
Fantasy Agito 13 and Final Fantasy
Versus 13 the three would become the
fabula Nova crystallis series where the
games would all share a common mythology
flash forward a few years and we've had
1313 - and lightning returns agate
overcame type-0 and released on PSP and
as for vs. 13 next week it's finally
being released into the wild as Final
Fantasy 15 a lot can change in 10 years
so this week on in two minutes brought
to you by Final Fantasy 15 here's
exactly how the game evolved from verses
13 to 15 vs. 13 was announced at e3 2006
as a ps3 exclusive to be developed by
the Kingdom Hearts team Square Enix
creative Tetsuya Nomura famed for
directing Kingdom Hearts and designing
iconic characters such as cloud and
Sephiroth would helm the project it
could be argued that the game was
revealed way too soon as it wasn't
actually in full production at the time
with a 2008 interview with Nomura
suggesting that staff members were
constantly being shuffled onto other
priority projects such as Final Fantasy
13 and the relaunch of 14 the game was
constantly absent from gaming shows
fueling rumors that it had been quietly
cancelled but various short trailers
were eked out showing brief glimpses at
verses 13 in January 2011 five years
after the initial reveal the first real
gameplay footage was released the seven
minute long video showed combat new
areas and the player controlling not
only the lead character noctus but his
bodyguard advisor friends too in 2011
the developers also saw the Xbox one and
ps4 for the first time realising that
the new consoles would make the ps3
exclusive obsolete before it had even
launched in mid-2012 development was
shifted to next-gen and it was decided
that the engine be switched from crystal
tools to luminous studio in December
2012 type-0 director Hajime Tabata was
brought on board to co-direct and a year
later took over from Nomura completely
the type-0 team was added to the vs.
thirteen team and it was full steam
ahead
Tabata san as
mated that versus 13 was around 25%
complete by the time he took over it's
worth noting that in the time that
Nomura was in charge he also worked on
almost 18 other games in various roles
including pre-production on Kingdom
Hearts 3 tobacco sands first job was to
determine what would survive the
transition between directors the ability
to switch characters in combat was
scrapped as was the character Stella
who'd previously been seen in a few
trailers and was pitched as the game's
heroine the original intro that involved
an invasion by neighboring Kingdom
Niffleheim was reworked into the Kings
glaive movie then in June 2013 at e3
after years of cancellation rumours
Square Enix finally confirmed that vs.
13 was dead but would live on as Final
Fantasy 15 a playable demo episode -
skite was released in March 2015
followed by the Platinum demo a year
later and now 10 whole years since its
announcement the game releases next
Tuesday for more videos like this one
make sure to LIKE and subscribe to
GameSpot and for more of me you can find
me on Twitter at Lucy James games we'll
see you next time